welcome to this video I'm playing
anti-drone from the UK I keep forgetting
who this is and I keep stumbling to the
Trump against the English guys I playing
the trumpet scheme ok this is Richard
put it doesn't have the name in there
but he he wrote this book on the Trump
so it's great i need to i played the
trumpet gainst this book author what the
heck ok what does solid here Knight d4
and d5 as a solid move this is what
Boris a brook suggested in his in his
book or maybe 96 I don't know this is
just transposing into London London
system move down but it's still pretty
harmless so at least here I'm not
getting into some some tactical some
tactical haired storm that he analyzed
for the book in fact him he sacked upon
and I'm really i really don't know if
this is so any good
90 mm maybe six let's let's just bolster
the center a bit of course it's a
typical my queen bee 6 queen bee to the
fair where you where you snatch the pawn
it can always blow up in your face even
if it is a form of the of the pawn grab
where maybe objectively it's not so
great especially in blitz I don't I
cannot really assess this I don't know
but for now we should play for otherwise
okay this is also an idea try to trap
the Queen so I'm I'm going all the way
back
yeah I don't want to take and open up
the position oh this is interesting that
he allows that
of course it was hanging but okay yeah
you are already already upon down anyway
I know but b5 looks like a move that
might help me protect c4 and maybe
allows even to take I came interesting
ok but I must do this yeah I must
protect me five and maybe I get a six
what I definitely don't do is castle
quickly v5 night moves Bishop h7 or
something I don't do that one positive
feature are not down on the clock okay
just here and at least liar Miami center
the center is closed so this is okay and
he can he can take on age seven maybe
you should hoping for 4g six which I
won't play of course okay take the pawn
and then see what what's next maybe just
bishop to be 7 a-5 and before road the
pawns as long as my king is only a term
he doesn't really have an attack
okay so should I just take it yeah come
on just take it now let's run the pawns
up the board okay here maybe a five yeah
f5 rook h7 fe 6 this is some this is
dangerous after f5 though I could just
take a five because of the the b6 pin
here
how to how to defend this not so easy
okay and this is a bit passive but I
didn't see the good defense besides that
now now push push the pawns
yeah i'll i'll play be three a duet be
three a four get the spawns at the board
so that i only need to survive on the
King side so to have those those winning
pawns okay takes Knight takes bishop g6
is a possibility but g5 hangs
Wow Niq 495 is this this this good
thank you I don't know yeah and I won't
be able to calculate it
takes takes bishop g6 King g7 um I don't
know hey maybe I'm 88 or something check
it could happen
check
check now only need to not get mated
then my pawns win the game it's it's
easy in a way check check
time warning
check
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check check check wyd for her Wow
oh my god okay I have no idea what was
it at the end I'm a piece down I
couldn't even look at to look at the
board I mean what a game I had screen b3
mate couldn't be three mate yeah he's
telling me one movie his right but of
course I mean like was completely
winning of course there's no way that
this attack is really sound around here
I mean I've got those two bonds bishop
is there won't be seven is to draw
according to the computer yeah then
black is winning before I ad- for
something okay it says it doesn't really
matter with this time it's just okay
this is winning channel check kick be
eight yeah and you know b1 b1 is the win
but they okay I had 20 seconds I mean
just check this wins as well this does
change okay what can you do it's a
complete instability in st. end of this
and she NT he would have mated me with
just one more second on the clock
alright so I hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching